امي قطعت كل العلاقات مع منذ العام 2009
منذ الانتخابات التي جرت في ذلك الوقت
وهمم منذ فتره طويله تم قطع العلاقات معهم
في كل المجالات
[موسيقى]
قريبا الاخرين بطبيعه الحال
هناك
الكثير وحتى من طرف خالي وفي عائله خالي
هنالك من يعارض
السياسه التي يقوم بها او التي تسير عليها
البلاد خلال السنوات الماضيه همم
الحال هم موجودين ولكن همم لا يمكنهم همم
لا يمكننا الخروج للتظاهر والتعبير عن
حرياتهم
[موسيقى]
شوقي
قتله لسبب وحيد
النظام
ابن ابنه مصطفى كان صديقه في يوم من
الايام
[موسيقى]
علي خانقني يمكن ان يعين شخص قبل وفاته
ولكن اذا توفي فان هذا النظام لن يصمد
مرشح لخلافه والده لان النظام يمكن ان
يتلاشى
وستكون هنالك حرب داخليه داخل النظام
[موسيقى]